Salut les Épicurieuse et les Épicurieux.
Aujourd'hui, j'ai préparé une pizza.
Et c’est du boulot quand on veut respecter la tradition !
On n’imagine pas tout ce qui se cache
derrière cette spécialité italienne.
Pas seulement ses origines
ou sa composition,
mais aussi toutes les anecdotes
qui l’entourent.
Allez, aujourd’hui la pizza est reine…
de mon atelier.
Le mot pizza vient sans doute du grec:
pinta
qui désigne une sorte de galette de pain.
En Italie, il est utilisé
à partir du Xᵉ siècle,
mais attendez un peu
avant de vous lécher les babines.
Au début, il désigne une sorte de pain
plat de forme circulaire
ou des spécialités sucrées ou encore salées
comme les tourtes au fromage
ou à la viande.
La pizza telle que nous
la connaissons aujourd'hui
apparaît seulement vers le milieu
du XVIIIᵉ siècle, à Naples.
C'est un plat bon marché
que l'on déguste dans la rue
ou dans des restaurants spécialisés.
Les pizzerias, mais aussi aux champs.
Un célèbre pizzaïolo
napolitain Gino Sorbillo...
On dit qu’il fait les meilleures pizzas du monde.
Tu les as goûtées ?
.
Oui, et c'est vrai
qu'elles sont "molto bene" !
Bref, Gino m'a raconté qu'autrefois,
les paysans s'en nourrissaient aussi
quand ils travaillaient dans les champs,
La pizza était repliée 2 fois sur elle-même,
enveloppée dans du papier journal
et glissée dans la poche
intérieure de la veste.
Bon, valait mieux éviter la sauce tomate.
En 1889, Marguerite de Savoie
est de passage à Naples.
Raffaele Esposito, pizzaïolo napolitain,
est chargé de confectionner une pizza
afin de faire découvrir
la gastronomie locale à la reine.
Après avoir mûrement réfléchi,
il décide de napper sa pizza de sauce tomate,
puis de garnir le fond de mozzarella
et de déposer des feuilles de basilic.
Vert, blanc, rouge. Bien ouej !
Ce sont les couleurs du drapeau italien.
Bien vu, la pizza séduit les yeux
et le palais de la reine.
En son honneur,
cette pizza est nommée Margherita.
Et c’est aujourd’hui la pizza
la plus populaire du monde.
Au début du XXᵉ siècle, la pizza traverse
l'océan Atlantique.
Direction les Etats-Unis
avec les migrants napolitains partis s'installer à New York.
La première pizzeria américaine
ouvre ses portes dès 1905 : Lombardi's.
Elle est installée dans le quartier
de la Petite Italie dans Manhattan..
Petit à petit, la pizza séduit le cœur et
surtout l'estomac de tous les Américains.
Mais ce n'est qu'après
la Seconde Guerre mondiale
que la pizza devient populaire
partout dans le monde.
Et on en mange jusque dans l'espace.
Tenez, le 7 septembre 2021,
une soirée pizza
a même été organisée à bord de l'ISS.
Thomas Pesquet l'a filmée et l'a postée.
"On se croirait presque un samedi sur Terre.
On dit qu'un bon chef ne révèle jamais ses secrets.
Mais j'ai fait une vidéo
pour votre plaisir.
Tout sauf l'ananas. Ce serait une grave offense en Italie."
Evidemment les premières pizzas
n’avaient rien à voir
avec celles que l'on consomme aujourd'hui,
même à bord de l'ISS.
Jusqu'au début du XXᵉ siècle,
la pizza est fabriquée à partir d'une pâte très fine
agrémentée d'ail, d'huile d'olive, d'un peu de sauce tomate,
d'origan et parfois quelques
tranches de prosciutto.
Du jambon si vous préférez.
Parfois même de petits poissons.
Ce n’est qu’après la Seconde Guerre mondiale
qu’on a commencé à utiliser
de plus en plus d’ingrédients pour des garnitures
de plus en plus généreuses.
Dans les années 60,
un Canadien a même eu la drôle d'idée
d'y ajouter de l'ananas
pour créer la fameuse pizza hawaïenne.
Et aujourd'hui, il y en a
pour tous les goûts.
Et vous, avec quels ingrédients
la préférez-vous?
N'hésitez pas à partager vos goûts
et vos recettes en commentaires.
Moi, ma préférée,
c'est la reine, la Regina.
Et pour obtenir une pizza parfaite,
même les scientifiques ont mis la main à la pâte !
Si, si, c'est l'heure de l'ardoise.
La mathématicienne anglaise,
Eugenia Cheng, a établi la formule suivante :
t sur d, facteur de r6 sur r3 moins - 15².
Je savais bien que la pizza
c’était pas de la tarte !
Elle permet de déterminer
la bonne quantité de garnitures à utiliser
selon le diamètre de la pizza.
Car s'il n'y en a pas assez ...
On se mange les doigts ….
Et s'il y en a trop, la pizza est surchargée
et la pâte toute molle.
Tenez, en parlant de garniture,
des chercheurs néo-zélandais
ont voulu savoir quels fromages il fallait utiliser
pour faire la meilleure pizza possible.
Ils ont testé la mozzarella, l’édam,
l’emmental, le gruyère, et le cheddar.
À l’aide de caméras et de logiciels,
ils ont observé le brunissement, et la formation de petites bulles,
ainsi que le niveau de gras
de tous ces fromages après cuisson.
Leur conclusion : pour obtenir
le parfait équilibre entre texture et saveur,
rien de tel qu’un mélange
de mozzarella et de cheddar.
Sans oublier, bien sûr,
le tour de main du pizzaïolo.
Dans les pizzerias traditionnelles,
les maîtres pizzaïolos se produisent en public,
un peu comme des artistes.
Ils font tourner la pâte d'une main à l'autre
et la lancent dans les airs d'un geste très rapide.
Tiens, je vais essayer.
Allez, ça tourne, comme on dit.
Oh bah c'est malin !
C'est ce qu'on appelle recevoir un coup de “pâte”.
On peut dire ça.
En 2017, les Italiens ont fait inscrire
l'art du pizzaïolo napolitain
au patrimoine immatériel
de l'humanité de l'Unesco.
Il existe même des championnats
du monde de la pizza.
Des centaines de pizzaïolos
viennent du monde entier s'affronter
pour réaliser la plus grande pizza,
la plus rapidement préparée
ou tout simplement la meilleure pizza.
Quoi qu'il en soit, tous ces gestes
obéissent à des règles extrêmement précises..
Direction la cuisine.
Pour garnir la pâte, par exemple,
il faut impérativement placer les ingrédients
du centre vers l'extérieur, en tournant dans le sens
des aiguilles d'une montre,
et en formant un six imaginaire.
La pizza peut alors être mise à cuire.
Et dans un four chauffé avec du bois de hêtre !
Exclusivement du hêtre.
Et oui, à Naples,
on ne rigole pas avec la pizza.
En France non plus d’ailleurs,
il se vend plus d’un milliard de pizzas chaque année !
C’est l’équivalent de 10 kilogrammes
de pizzas par personne !
C'est simple avec les Américains,
nous sommes les plus gros consommateurs
de pizzas de la planète,
devant les Italiens.
Allez, il est l'heure de vous laisser.
Je vais prendre mes quartiers de pizza.
À très bientôt et si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner.
Je vais me régaler.